owning oneself is not an easy task  nietzsche looks at the world around him  and sees mainly people who prefer to be  dependent rather than independent  nietzsche believed that it's in our  passions where we find ourselves this  belief constituted one of his main  attempts to use philosophy as an  instrument to understand and engage with  a human psyche he does not want us to  suppress our instincts our passions our  emotions but to confront them and  embrace them that is how we understand  ourselves better that is how we own  ourselves without a deep understanding  of the nature of our inner world we are  just constantly exposed to a fake  reality and become victims to the twists  and turns of life we must constantly  test ourselves as he writes one must not  avoid one's tests although they  constitute perhaps the most dangerous  game one can play